un bus high tech pour aider les
demandeurs d'emploi et accompagner les
entreprises à recruter le département a
présenté ce lundi 13 septembre le bus
jobs l'insertion à nantes la ville une
première commune pas choisi au hasard
mantes-la-ville est une ville qui est en
difficulté au niveau de l'emploi et le
bus en insertion donc effectivement donc
le bienvenu ici donc nous on s'inscrit
dans lé à la fois dont l'huile est
tendue et une ville avec la nécessité de
l'insertion et de la recherche d'emploi
le projet mené par l' agence d'insertion
départementale activity pôle emploi et
les missions locales des yvelines
souhaite aller au devant des demandeurs
d'emploi en s'installant dans les
quartiers aujourd'hui d'un grand
département territorialement très
étendue il y à des personnes en
situation sociale difficile qui n'ont
pas de moyens de mobilité qui ne peuvent
donc pas se rendre dans les lieux où ils
sont susceptibles de toi non plus 18
communes ont été choisies pour un
premier tour d'un mois jusqu'au 8
octobre avec en moyenne trois passages
par ville c'est le principe assez il
faut que ça revienne régulièrement
puisque en fait le marché du travail
vous avez vu est très dynamique en ce
moment mais malheureusement le marché de
le chômage est aussi très dynamique et
donc il faut qu'on touche très très
régulièrement les demandeurs d'emploi et
les bénéficiaires du rsa
parmi les cibles préférentielles de
l'opération la jeunesse c'est une
nécessité effectivement on a parfois des
entreprises qui est cherche des
candidats on a des candidats mais qui
sont à l'autre bout des yvelines et
parfois sans moyen de transport donc
c'est vraiment essentiel de pouvoir
travailler sur cette question de la
mobilité entre espace d'accueil de
conseil ou encore d'informatique en
libre service le coût du véhicule
s'élève à hauteur de 378 euros financés
par le département